most of our competitors um I would
probably say all of them if not maybe
just a couple um it's just straight up
keyword monitoring. So you know you plug
in a couple of keywords and it'll look
it'll scrape across the internet across
social media for anything that just
contains that word. Um, and what that
very and end very often ends up meaning
for marketing teams is you're still then
stuck with hundreds and thousands of
things to look through um to make sure
that is this even worth your time. You
know, just because something mentions
marketing doesn't mean that the context
is right for
um for you to like actually do anything
with. Um so on the featurebased side um
our whole stick um our big like value
prop is that everything is prompt based.
So apart from filling in the keywords
that you want that the post has to
contain these certain keywords you can
give it all of that nuance kind of like
kind of like how you would prompt chat
GPT. So you can say like I'm looking for
posts in which people are saying that
they're having a very negative
experience with a competitor. So it's
not just that the competitor's name has
to be mentioned. It has to be a negative
experience. You can be as nuanced as you
want to be about it. Um and so like that
makes it much more actionable because it
is something that is um purposeful and
intent uh is an intent trigger for you.
[music]
>> Anna Law, thank you so much for joining
me on 20 minute leaders. I'm so excited
to have you here.
>> Of course, I'm excited to be here.
>> I I really love talking to founders as a
founder myself and um those are the
definitely the best episodes because uh
what leads you to start a company and
what leads you to have some insight and
some conviction over some world is
always fascinating for me. I think the
way your background works, you know,
coming from marketing and and and the
and pitch ghost, the company you
founded, I'm sure there was an
interesting story there with some
interesting insights as well as what
you're actually doing today. So again,
thank you for for taking these 20 short
minutes with me. I appreciate it.
>> Of course. Thanks for having me.
>> What what led you to start a company in
the social listening space?
>> Um, so I've always been a marketer by
trade. Um, and social listening was
something that was punted to me to do
manually across all the jobs that I had.
Um, so I was the person that had to kind
of like, you know, look at Reddit or
Twitter or Facebook manually to try and
find the kinds of like market insights,
competitive analysis, find posts in
which people are complaining about a
competitor seemingly organically and
then comment on it. Um, and the ROI on
it was great, but it was an extremely
extremely manual process and it took
hours and hours of my time. Um, and at
that time, um, you know, there were, we
still have like a couple of like
enterprise competitors. Um, but we were
so priced out like I've been in the
startup game. Um, and you know,
something that costs like $5,000 a month
was just absolutely not an option. Um,
there was no way that any of my bosses
would ever have signed up on that,
signed off on that. Um, so it was just
my part of my job. Like it was just I
had to allocate a couple of hours of my
day every day to do that. Um,
>> so, um, kind of serendipitously,
I bumped into my co-ound now co-founder
at the Atlanta Tech Village. Um he was
working on a different startup at the
time and um he had built what is now
Pitch Ghost as kind of like an internal
tool just for himself to help market
that startup. Um and so he put together
this like just scrappy Twitter scraper
um just to help him find posts for that
company and that was like his outbound
system. So he wasn't he's not from like
marketing or anything. and he's like
he's a developer so you know he even he
was like I see the value and like you
know that just sounds like great
outbound like you know find the exact
right post and if I comment on it it's
kind of like SEO that also lives forever
um and it's onetoone so he built this
little scraper that would like find a
couple of posts every single day for him
and queue it up and give him a little
drafted response and then he could just
like copy that response and stick it in
that post and that was like his outbound
sales marketing whatever done for the
day.
>> Um, so he had built that as a tool for
himself and just being in the village,
this Atlanta Tech village like
ecosystem, I guess other people around
him um saw what he had built and what he
was doing with it and that kind of
piqued their interest. Um, you know, oh,
like can I can I use that tool to find X
Y and Z for myself? Um, and I suppose
that enough people around him said that
that when we met, he was in the process
of platformizing Pitch Ghost and
abandoning the other startup.
>> Um, and so, you know, he was looking for
a co-founder to come on to do more of
like the marketing and sales, like all
of the non-technical stuff, right?
>> Um, and so when I heard about the idea,
I was like, this is fantastic cuz it
actually solves the pain point that I
have. Um, and you know, marketing teams
are doing this. They either have an
extremely extremely extremely expensive
solution or they're having to do this
manually, but it is a practice across
the board because PE teams are seeing
value in social listening. Um, so yeah,
I'm kind of I'm your girl like I'm the
right person to talk in the same
language as um the marketers and be able
to position this in a way that's
compelling in the marketplace. So when
you talk about so one of the ways that
you're positioning this is actionable
social listening.
>> Yeah.
>> Why why the word actionable? Uh it
sounds to me that every action that or
every solution in the market for
organizations needs to have some
actionability to it. Uh why did you and
why did you add the word actionable
before social listening?
>> So um for two reasons. One more
literally featurebased is that um most
of our competitors um I would probably
say all of them if not maybe just a
couple. Um it's just straight up keyword
monitoring. So you know you plug in a
couple of keywords and it'll look it'll
scrape across the internet, across
social media for anything that just
contains that word. Um, and what that
very and end very often ends up meaning
for marketing teams is you're still then
stuck with hundreds and thousands of
things to look through um to make sure
that is this even worth your time. You
know, just because something mentions
marketing doesn't mean that the context
is right for
um for you to like actually do anything
with. Um so on the feature based side um
our whole stick um our big like value
prop is that everything is prompt based.
So apart from filling in the keywords
that you want that the post has to
contain these certain keywords you can
give it all of that nuance kind of like
kind of like how you would prompt chat
GPT.
>> So you can say like I'm looking for
posts in which people are saying that
they're having a very negative
experience with a competitor. So it's
not just that the competitor's name has
to be mentioned. It has to be a negative
experience. You can be as nuanced as you
want to be about it. Um and so like that
makes it much more actionable because it
is something that is um purposeful and
intent uh is an intent trigger for you.
Um and then secondarily um we help you
respond to every single post that we
give you. Um so we also haven't seen
that on the marketplace really very
often. um where most since it's mainly
like a keyword tracking software that
most competitors have um that's just the
core functionality like they'll just
surface these things to you and then the
marketing team figures out like okay
like what do I now like do I want to
comment on it do I want to repost it
whatever like you figure it out from
there um whereas with pitch ghost we
give you drafted responses to everything
>> so if you opt into it we'll write like
um we'll write the copy for you can
always edit it we'll have that like in
the tone of your messaging and your
brand voice and everything. Um, you
know, it's got all the context of the
post of what you do, everything. And
anything that you could do on LinkedIn
or Reddit or Twitter or wherever, you
can do those, perform those actions
directly from within pitch. Um, so it
helps you just like helps teams keep
track of like what did they do with it,
when did they do it, who said what, did
anything come out of that. Um, so it
becomes more of an ecosystem versus just
a keyword tracker tool that you know is
kind of off in the distance somewhere
doing its own thing.
>> No, it makes a ton of sense. Tell me so
tell me you know the founding time of of
of pitch ghost. How do you you you have
the solution already because your
co-founder has been using it internally.
You are coming in with the insights of
what's been lacking. what sounds to me
more
companies that their budgets for these
types of solutions is lower. So you you
it sounds like you want to penetrate the
market for companies who are not
necessarily spending the 50,000 or
$60,000 a year for these enterprise
solutions. You want to make it more
accessible. Um how do you go from there?
What happens then?
Um so right now like RA IP has been
defined extremely extremely narrowly but
that took a lot of time. Um you know in
the beginning you get as a founder
everybody kind of tells you like oh I
love what you're doing and like I want
to buy that and that sounds cool. So you
end up selling it to anybody and
everybody. um which you know it's it's
really hard to avoid because people get
excited about things and you know in
theory the idea of finding your
customers online is a very exciting
novel idea for any kind of business
right um so it took us a lot of time in
the beginning of like trial and error of
finding who the right demographic is you
know specific titles the specific types
of companies that um we are a really
good fit for um and any of the other
qualifying behavior. So now we're at a
stage where we can define that extremely
well, but it took like a year of trial
and error of having multiple different
types of personalities and personas that
we were selling to um and learning about
their use cases and even that's been
really interesting just seeing the ways
in which people have gotten really
really creative with how they're using
Pitch Coast.
>> Yeah, sure. and tell me a little bit
about about that discovery process and
the validation process that you did for
for those use cases. How how did you
actually go about that?
>> So um in the beginning we started off
with just Twitter. So we didn't do
anything else. It was just Twitter. Um
and that's when I joined. Um, and that
time that it was like maybe like the
first 3 months it was really hard um to
find people that would get excited about
just Twitter. Um, and that market was
pretty narrow, right? Like um, so it it
was difficult for us to kind of like
think about like do I you know the
people that really really love Twitter
like let's say like the crypto bros,
right? is that like do we want if we go
down that route, do we want to be
married to that demographic or do we and
then do we build just for them because
we're starting with Twitter or do we
build for this like bigger vision of
like we you know we expect to roll out
the other stuff um and does that like
isolate us out like does that change the
messaging does it change marketing does
it not you know um so we chose the
latter option where um we you know We
went after um some some like crypto and
like some f like any of the demographics
that did lean into Twitter very heavily.
Um but we very very quickly um it became
really just like the amount of feedback
we were booking a lot of meetings. We
were doing cold outbound a lot and we
use pitch ghost every single day at
pitch ghost. like you know I was getting
a lot of meetings booked and I was
speaking with um marketing teams and
sales teams about pitch ghost um and
everybody not everybody but like let's
say like 80% of the calls I had would be
like this sounds cool love the demo I
want to buy it call me when you have
LinkedIn
>> um and so it was just the overwhelming
number of people that that was the top
choice they
>> because what for what so what use case
were they using it for for for sales for
marketing on LinkedIn B2B I guess.
>> Yeah, I mean it tended to be a little
bit more on the B2B side but not
necessarily. I think it was just it's it
LinkedIn still is our highest like
perceived value. So most people will buy
us because we have LinkedIn and it's
really really hard to support LinkedIn.
Um most of our competitors don't even
the enterprisegrade ones can't do the
LinkedIn the way that we're able to do
it. So, it's a big like value driver um
for the sales cycle. Um but it's
interesting like most people
perceptually come come because we can do
LinkedIn um and then they end up finding
the most value in Reddit maybe or
something else. Um but um but yeah so it
was you know we we built LinkedIn it
took some time um and in that time you
know we were still doing a lot of the
customer discovery. So initially um my
co-founder when he had kind of like
platformized pitch ghost he wanted me to
test the theory of if early stage
founders would be a good good fit for us
because he was from that world like
right he was like I built this tool to
like you know I'm a solo founder this
going to help me do my sales so we test
that hypothesis of like is this a good
tool for just like solo founder that has
no team has no revenue um is this
something that they will lose. So, in
the beginning when we especially just
had Twitter, we had a lot a lot of like
solo founders. Um, and very quickly, um,
that ended up not being a fit.
>> Um, so, you know, they hung around for a
month, 2 months, but then what we
learned was just they churned like crazy
because a founder when they have another
team, they're doing like 500 different
things, you know, like something else is
always more important.
>> Yes. And it it didn't matter how sticky
the product was. It was just not as much
of a priority as you know like building
a cap table or going and doing a race or
going you know like and that's fair like
fair enough like you're just you've got
500 different things to do. Um so it
just wasn't um working out as that being
the demographic. Um, so then we looked
at teams that, you know, maybe it's like
a maybe you have two to three people. So
at least there's like one marketing
person on that team and that's there or
a salesperson, but it's like that's
somebody's job and it's not the founder.
Um, or it could be the founder, but like
it's not it's not just one person on the
team basically. Um, and so we tried that
and that was a little better. So we
still have a couple of customers that
kind of fit into like a very under very
early stage like under five people kind
of company. Um and that's still it's
been a hit or miss. It's been a hit or
miss because we kind of run into the
same issues of where like it's a little
bit more sticky. It is somebody's core
like responsibility but it's still if
it's like only one person in charge of
sales and marketing even that you can
you you're a little touch and go of like
if some if you know if a different
campaign becomes more important you
might abandon this product. Um but so
we've kind of now found our sweet spot
of marketing and sales teams. So like
the rev ops or go to market team
basically because it can be a
combination of the marketing and sales
people together um and really built for
teams. So built for that collaboration
um at you know companies that are
startups really high growth startups
that are between like five to let's say
a 100 employee size.
>> Um so you know there's an actual like
marketing or there's an actual sales
team where there's multiple people
involved. um and and that way they see
the most value out of it. So when they
have they're a content marketer and they
also have some B2B LinkedIn SAS person
on there and they also have you know
these just these different titles and
they all see the value in it because
they're all kind of collaborating on one
platform but for so many varied revops
use cases. That's been her first
>> is social is social listening
historically servicing go to market
teams and sales teams because uh it
seems to me that more of it we used to
be targeting more so the brand
>> the brand team the marketing team.
>> Exactly. So they historically have
served um the marketing team um at very
very large companies or the PR or like
PR firms. So most social listening
software will be, you know, like let's
say Coca-Cola wants to see how many
times was Coca-Cola mentioned in today
in Argentina or something, right?
Something super super specific, but they
see value in that because they're so
massive and they're mentioned so many
times that that data is valuable versus
for a startup, you know, you might you
might you're probably not mentioned five
times a year anywhere. um and you
instead just want to focus more on the
lead genen and demand genen side to try
and build that reputation and that trust
in the market. Um, so we did that and
that's kind of why we leaned he more
heavy towards the rev ops and the go to
market side for people um is that
traditional social listening software
was so heavily focused on brand
monitoring and keyword tracking um that
it only made sense like it there was
only you could only see the value for it
if you were an enterprise level
customer.
>> Mhm. Makes a ton of sense. What so where
is this heading? Where do you see pitch
ghost in several years? Um, so we're
building like crazy. We're growing like
crazy. Um, and so this year we're
focusing a lot on integrations and
becoming a bigger part of our our
customers tech stack. So um, until about
maybe like October of last year, um, you
know, we didn't have a ton of
integration. So it was like it was still
a platform you use separately and you
would kind of manually take this data
somewhere else and do maybe like a lot
of our customers do cold outbound for
example. Um so you would kind of like
export this information and put it
somewhere else put it in your CRM put it
in Apollo put it wherever. Um
>> so we're building now more towards like
how does this become integrated into
whatever tech stack or whatever tools
you're already using. So the information
can transfer really easily. Um you can
kind of imagine it being a little bit
more like clayesque in that like we want
the posts we give you to be this top of
the funnel and it's all kind of in one
platform that you can do a bunch of
different things inside or take it and
do something with the data we give you
in a platform that you're more
comfortable with. Um so with things like
that, you know, we've released web
hooks, we're probably going to release
an API soon. Um, and we're just building
tons of integrations. So, we're working
on an Apollo integration. We built a
HubSpot integration. Um, and we're
seeing people do a lot of cool things
with it. Um, so I think the vision is
just that we live in a really happy
place. Um, wherever our customer wants
us to live, um, versus having to just
rely on like our app, right?
>> Um,
>> and apart from that, I mean, we're
growing our team. So, we brought on team
members earlier this year and that's
been awesome. So, we're just kind of
ramping up um bisops on our side. We
hired a developer as well to kind of
keep up with all of our um feature
requests and road maps and things like
that. And yeah, um you know, hopefully
we're kind of
>> super exciting.
>> It's exciting. It It's a grind, but it's
exciting.
>> I love it. Anya, thank you so much for
joining me. It was a priv privilege
listening to to your journey and the
insights leading up to Pitch Ghost and
what's up ahead. So, thank you so much
for being here. Of course. Thank you.
Have a good rest of your day.